With 80% of infectious diseases spread by
our hands, it’s clear that washing them
is important. But, when it comes to your hygiene
and cleanliness, which method of drying is
best? Using a classic paper towel, or the
hand dryer?
Well, you’ll be happy to know that if you
wash your hands properly with soap, nearly
all traces of bacteria will be removed, regardless
of how you dry them. But it’s when you don’t
wash properly, or even worse, only wash with
water, that how you dry your hands can make
all the difference. After all, the spread
of bacteria is more likely to occur with wet
skin, and rubbing your wet hands on your clothes
or touching the bathroom door can often contaminate
them even more.
It turns out, after multiple studies were
analyzed and compared, paper towels came out
victorious. Why? A lot of it has to do with
timing. The average air dryer requires nearly
45 seconds to reduce hand moisture by 97%,
whereas paper towel users achieve the same
thing in around only 10 seconds. But after
reviewing people’s behaviour, studies showed
that most individuals spent only 22 seconds
with an air dryer, leaving their hands less
than 70% dry. Paper towel users, on the other
hand, could achieve more than 85% dryness
with only 5 seconds.
Friction also plays a key role in the removal
of bacteria, with much of it being transferred
right on to the paper towel. Conversely, some
studies have shown that hand dryers may actually
emit bacteria in their flow, because of the
contaminated air from the bathroom. Having
said that, air drying hands can be effective
if done thoroughly, and truthfully, you don’t
always have an option! Though some dryers
are much better than others, just make sure
you dry them fully, and it shouldn’t be
a major problem.
What about the environment, you ask? Without
a doubt, new dryers are the environmentally
friendly option. Not only because they prevent
deforestation, but they actually use less
energy and have a lower carbon emission once
everything is taken into account. After all,
13 billion pounds of paper towel are used
every year in America alone - and that’s
their major pitfall.
So if you’re going to use paper towel, here’s
a quick tip that only requires one piece,
as suggested by advocate Joe Smith. After
washing your hands, shake them hard 12 times,
then fold the piece of paper in half, and
wipe like so. This is the optimal arrangement
to dry with the least amount of paper. Again,
shake your hands 12 times...fold, and dry.
Now you have clean dry hands, with minimal
waste!
Special thanks to Audible.com for supporting
this episode and giving you a free audio book
of your choice at audible.com/asap. Audible
is the leading provider of audiobooks with
over 150,000 downloadable titles across all
types of literature. We recommend the book
“Guns, Germs, and Steel” by Jared Diamond
which breaks down the rise of civilizations
across the globe and refutes the ideas of
human development based on race! It also touches
on how germs may have a played a large role
in our evolutionary past. You can download
this audio book or another of your choice,
for free, at audible.com/asap. And with a
subscription you get one free book a month!
Special thanks Audible for making these videos
possible!
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!